as a friend who cares about you do it
jump rope or what show
[Music]
guys today we're talking about
supercomputers
look at this thing son hey it says
Cordova huh plastic dude that's pretty
special a couple of months ago when we
were working on a video called they've
God we started running into issues and
that issue was render time because in
that video there is tons of smoke
simulations we were spending hours upon
hours upon hours rendering these effects
out by pure coincidence the guys at
Puget systems hit us up around that time
you're like hey we build
professional-grade computers for
workstations and this is an important
difference this isn't a gaming PC this
is an actual workstation this is meant
to be a beast for rendering for working
and for creating the types of videos
that we like to make you should touch it
if you haven't touched it yet I'm just
rubbing putting my breezy prints all
over this plug it in so these are for
NVIDIA GTX 1080s
the best GPUs you can get on the market
these are the best GPUs you can get as
of late summer 2016 best GPUs on the
market those are the best GPUs I've ever
seen with my own eyes these GPUs are so
crazy I just from worst to best
GPUs those are the best GPUs
the scars on the market no idea how
excited I am finally where do I put it
so cliquey the reason why I've not been
able to use this computer for last - we
just because I was in the middle of a
project I had project files set up on
this computer I had all my plugins
installed what that means is that now I
have to find out what is on that
computer by first moving this one hit
the power button unplug everything
oh my these things weigh like 30 pounds
now I got a plug in all the cables
coke surge protector you get a power
surge the breaker road trip ah I'm sure
you know what you are doing ordinary he
look at it they got a plug in your
mother cramping I'm gonna truth yeah
ah hey it's uh why does it say sign in a
Jake hello you hear that my name is
surrender I am here to surrender I don't
know how I feel about that
would you like to install your programs
and plugins yes
formatting server no no no stop stop
hiko did you hear that but that was you
that wasn't me that's exactly right I am
here to render for you remember the shot
invade me out of hand when Nico comes
back to life after being killed by babe
so I started the renders at 9:30 p.m.
and it ended at 8:50 a.m. that was 11
hours to render so let's see there's
like a hundred and seventy ish frames
the first few frames only took like a
couple minutes but by the end when
there's a lot of smoke it was taking
upwards of like five or six minutes per
frame that's a lot of time starting from
scratch for this frame
so fast look at that it's going to take
24 seconds instead of five minutes oh my
god like before that was a five-minute
render and it did it in 22 seconds on
this new machine this changes everything
oh my god I can't handle it this is
great now this obviously wouldn't be a
very good computer setup if we didn't
actually get to stress test it check
this out I took some spheres and I made
them emit colored light threw that into
the smoke and this is the ultimate test
for octane because this takes a very
very long time to render out octane is
just like it's taking all the co2 cores
it can possibly take to render faster
and faster almost kind of ironic because
there aren't really many other pieces of
software we have here that utilize that
many graphics cards octane fortunately
utilizes them brilliantly and that's why
we have an entire render machine
dedicated to just octane cards another
piece of software at DaVinci color
grading or editing or editing right am i
helping it's the kind of thing that this
wouldn't exist without this computer
because I'm not going to just sit here
and let this render for three days or
some shot that I just want to throw on
Instagram would you do that Nico yes
would you pay ready to that but no huge
thanks to Puget systems for making this
computer putting it together you can
check them out on Twitter not being paid
to talk about this at all they made us
computer and we're like sure we'll talk
about it you give us a computer oh my
god jump right there
[Music]
oh yeah I think